the movie opens with a glimpse into the
lives of three different married couples
the first one comprises Cosimo and
Bianca who look happy with their
relationship and are close to one
another contrastingly Carlotta and Lele
are the second couple who appear to be
experiencing tension in their
relationship Lele can be seen messaging
someone hiding in the bathroom while
Carlotta is drinking wine alone and
changing her undergarments at last we
are introduced to a therapist surgeon
pair named Eva and Rocco despite being a
therapist Eva experiences difficulties
in parenting her 17 year old daughter
Sophia after finding a packet of
protection in her bag she shouldn't be
using those she informs Rocco about the
same but the two seem to have Divergent
opinions over how to care for Sophia
Rocco wants to let their daughter
explore new things by herself come on
honey this is awkward but Eva thinks
otherwise in the next scene we get to
know that the three couples are set to
meet for a dinner party Eva and Rocco
are the organizers and they have made
sure to prepare all of their favorite
dishes after a while happy couple
Carlotta and Lele arrive bringing in a
homemade meal Ava and Rocco give them a
warm welcome and as they begin
discussing their lives Cosimo and Bianca
also arrived there after all three
couples gather they begin talking about
Pepe the seventh buddy who is divorced
and is currently with his new girlfriend
lucila everyone seems very eager to meet
her and they declare Pepe to be the
luckiest one the friends then begin
assuming the age and appearance of
Lucilla who appears to be the focus of
their conversation shortly after Pepe
finally shows up but he is all alone
without his girlfriend seeing this his
friends become immensely disappointed
they asked Pepe about Lucille's absence
and he replies that she couldn't attend
the party due to her sickness after a
little bit of discussion about Pepe's
life all of them sit for dinner they
talk about a variety of topics including
how they are facing problems
understanding each other at times
between this they also discuss how one
of their acquaintances lives was wrecked
by a text message that revealed her
spouse was having an affair this
discussion gives rise to differ offering
perspectives and viewpoints on who is at
fault some believe the lady should not
have checked her Man's phone while the
guys believe the mail should have been
more cautious and should have deleted
the message red flags red flags
everywhere due to the minor debate Eva
says that mobile phones are tiny black
boxes which contain dark secrets of life
it is so dangerous that it can even
wreck marriages Carlotta concurs with
Eva claiming that Lele her husband has
never shown his phone to her and even
carries it to the bathroom hearing this
Lele tries to prove that he has nothing
to hide from his wife so he puts his
phone on the table the others also
support him and add that their close
friends who have no secrets between them
meanwhile being a therapist Eva decides
to make the situation more entertaining
she suggests playing a game where
everyone must put their phones on the
dining room table and while eating if
they get any messages or calls they
should share it with the group at first
most of them hesitate to take part in
the game but to show that they have no
secrets they eventually agree and put
their mobile phone on the table just as
the game is about to start Eva and
Rocco's daughter Sophia arrives there
greets everyone and takes her father
aside she then asks Rocco for some money
and leaves for her friend's house to
attend a party just then Cosimo receives
a sensual text message from an unknown
number startling his wife Bianca all
others start questioning him about the
sender but soon it is revealed that the
message is actually from Rocco who is
trying to prank casimo or was he after
this the game begins at first everyone
appears to be in a good mood and they
play practical jokes tease and argue
with one another Cosimo even brings out
the incidents about their adulthood and
makes fun of his friends in between
Rocco and Lele go to the kitchen and
discuss the future trial of Lele and
carlotta's relationship here it is
revealed that Lele and Carlotta are not
on good terms and are trying to separate
in the next scene Eva gets a call from
her father she tells him that her
friends are around but despite this the
old man discloses that Eva is having
augmentation memoplasty a cosmetic
procedure for the bosoms as everyone
stares at her in disbelief Eva defends
herself by stating that she is happy
with her appearance except for her
bosoms Bianca however claims that being
a therapist herself she must accept her
body as it is and should Advocate the
same for others this makes things seem a
little more serious and Again Sparks a
fresh round of varying viewpoints some
of them criticize her for not going to
her own husband Rocco for the procedure
this Sparks a discussion between Eva and
Rocco compelling them to bring their
interpersonal issues to the dinner table
later Pepe and Lele take a little break
to smoke outside watching over the lunar
eclipse here Lele reveals that a friend
of his sends him an explicit picture
every night at 10 o'clock as there will
be chaos if Carlotta finds out he begs
Pepe's assistants to help him out of the
situation Lele then requests him to
exchange their phones for the time being
as they are of the same brand Pepe first
objects to the notion but in the end he
caves into lele's emotional coercion and
agrees to help meanwhile Eva and
Carlotta are in the kitchen when the
latter reveals that Eva's husband Rocco
is attending therapy later everyone
again gathers around the dinner table
and more texts messages and calls come
in they all thoroughly enjoy making fun
of and joking about with one another
right then Rocco unintentionally spills
wine on himself and Eva follows him to
the other room to help him clean the
mess up using this opportunity Eva asks
him about the therapy he has been
receiving Rocco responds that he's been
going for six months and wanted to keep
it a secret until he completes it Eva
becomes obsessed he admits that he wants
to give things a go before they even try
to split sometime later Pepe receives
the photo from lele's anticipated friend
on WhatsApp and everyone starts
criticizing him unbeknownst to the fact
that it is not his phone on the other
hand Lele also receives a text message
from a person named Lucio asking him how
he is this makes Pepe quite anxious and
he starts emphasizing how these phones
violate one's privacy and disrupt lives
it's definitely the phones not the
people who own them everyone is shocked
by a startling outburst and so Lele
decides against replying to the see us
taxed later Carlotta receives a message
offering various services and discounts
from an old age home valet is really
offended by this as his old mother also
lives with them in the family while he
acknowledges that his mother may be a
challenge at times he doesn't want to
place her in an old age care home in the
following scene when it is about 10
o'clock everyone decides to watch the
eclipse from the balcony in an effort to
ease the situation after observing the
beautiful scenery for a while they
propose to take a group photo on
Bianca's phone unfortunately just as
they are about to take a group photo she
receives some texts from her ex in
Raging Cosimo and making him feel
envious however before things can heat
up Bianca manages to calm him down with
a convincing explanation at last Lele
suggests Bianca give her ex the phone
number of Eva mentioning that he needs a
therapist instead of an ex-girlfriend
following that Sophia calls her dad
Rocco and asks for his opinion about
sleeping with her boyfriend as expected
he gives Sophia the right advice and
encourages her to embrace her
independent pursue her true happiness
here she also reveals that her dad is
the one who handed her the protection
earlier after hearing how Rocco handled
the situation even Eva values her
husband and appreciates his counseling
next Lele receives yet another text from
Lucio and this time he chooses to text
back and inform him that he is at a
party with his friends unfortunately
things quickly spiral out of control
when Lucio calls and yells at him
admitting that they are in a
relationship everyone is shocked by this
news and they start thinking that Lele
is gay not realizing that the phone
actually belongs to Pepe Lele makes an
attempt to cover it up but things get
quite complicated as both his wife
Carlotta and Cosimo grow upset and to
disrespectful towards him even though
Pepe tries to clear up the misconception
Lele forbids him since he has had enough
of their attitudes and reprimands them
for their narrow-mindedness while the
situation is getting tense Cosimo
receives a call from a man inquiring if
his girl liked the earrings he sent
Cosimo tries to avoid the conversation
but everyone has already heard it
because Bianca doesn't wear earrings and
doesn't even have her ears pierced she
is Disturbed when the two are arguing
Cosimo's taxi dispatcher contacts him
Bianca hurriedly picks it up and gets to
know that the woman is actually pregnant
and is holding Cosimo's child what is
even the [__] anymore hearing this
Bianca completely loses her control so
she and Carlotta lock themselves in the
bathroom in the meantime Eva pulls
Cosimo aside takes off her earrings
gives them back to him and spits in his
face calling him disgusting when Rocco
sees Eva upset he attempts to console
her but she just keeps crying without
speaking to him on the other hand Lele
approaches the bathroom and hands
Carlotta her phone with a very private
message from a Facebook friend Carlotta
becomes agitated by this and tells him
he is just a random Facebook user she
doesn't even know following this the
situation becomes even more gloomy when
Carlotta sobs while discussing how she
was to blame for the vehicle accident
for which Lele is currently facing legal
proceedings what's going on afterward as
Carlotta departs she makes fun of lele's
homosexuality at this moment Pepe
ultimately admits that he is the one who
is homosexual and not Lele he continues
by expressing his disappointment in
everyone for their hypocrisy moreover he
warns them that he would never introduce
his beloved whom he had named Lucio out
of concern that their weird looks and
behavior May harm him later the group
starts to worry about Bianca who is
still confined in the bathroom when she
doesn't respond to anything they Smash
down the door to check if she's all
right surprisingly Bianca is calmly
applying lipstick she then lays her
wedding ring on the table after which
she taunts everyone for their hypocrisy
and leaves surprisingly in the next
scene everyone appears to be departing
the party after having a good time they
laugh and embrace each other as if
everything is well lighter aziva and
Rocco go to their bedroom following the
party it is then revealed that Rocco
forbade them from playing the phone game
and the chaotic situation never took
place he stopped the game by mentioning
that it's best not to toy with these
phones because they can retain the most
Intimate Secrets Eva expresses her
concern that he could be keeping secrets
of his own but he laughs at this and
hands her his phone he also claims that
he has nothing to hide and then turns to
leave after praising Eva's earrings the
movie then ends with everyone mentioning
that they had a good time at Eva and
Rocco's place so what we saw was just a
dream or a dark timeline or were we just
watching a movie subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching